un lavabo à la main en allusion à
l'expression anglaise thinkin qui
signifie que les gens doivent se faire à
l'idée que c'est lui le nouveau patron
de Twitter
Elon Musk n'en est pas à une
extravagance près
et il a ça veut dire tout ça veut dire
le grand ménage l'efficacité
puis les profits ça veut aussi dire pour
ilon musk la liberté de l'oiseau symbole
du réseau qu'il a payé 44 milliards de
dollars tout en montrant la porte au PDG
de Twitter et au directeur financier et
juridique il se rebaptise shiftweet d'un
réseau social de 486 millions
d'utilisateurs qui se classe au 14e rang
de popularité dans le monde et qui
n'atteint que 21 millions de
consommateurs
réduire les effectifs ça c'est un
message très concret qui l'envoie après
par la suite mais là ça va passer par
d'autres choses il va falloir rendre la
plateforme plus intéressante pour les
annonceurs ce qui a pas été le cas il y
a beaucoup d'annonceurs qui sont partis
le retour espéré des publicitaires mais
également de Donald Trump qui se réjouit
que Twitter soit désormais entre de
bonnes mains sur sa plateforme trutho
show il écrit que tout et ne sera plus
dirigé par les fous de la gauche
radicale qui détestent véritablement
notre pays mais est-ce le retour de
l'extrême droite la symbolique de dire
qu'on va réouvrir Twitter finalement à
quelqu'un qui répondait pendant la
pandémie des fausses informations qui a
encouragé une partie de de manifestants
de de tenter de renverser le Capitole au
mois de janvier alors on peut se
demander si la place de la science et
des faits va pas diminuer sur Twitter
faudra voir comment à l'intérieur de
Twitter on va modérer à tous ces propos
là parce que c'est une chose d'être en
faveur de la libre expression mais
est-ce qu'on est en faveur de la
diffamation des menaces de la
désinformation c'est là où elle est
masque va être testé dans son leader
chef à la plateforme celui qui a conquis
le transport sur terre et dans l'espace
avec Tesla et SpaceX se lance à présent
à la conquête de nos écrans l'homme le
plus riche du monde avait annoncé début
octobre que tout est un été qu'un
premier pas vers la création d'une super
application portant le nom de X ici
Yasmine rayat Radio-Canada Montréal